what's up guys and welcome to Harley's
hobbies the channel where we discussed
the latest tech news and dog into newest
tech products today we're taking a look
at why interior is finally officially
dead
and how miners are scrambling to make
their money back and the new algorithm
that is upcoming for a theorem possibly
but before we begin that make sure to
subscribe to this channel if you haven't
already to be updated with the latest
tech news related to gaming and pcs so
why is it theorem dead and what's
happening to it well if you guys didn't
already know if the game has been
consistently going down in price for the
last couple of months for example in
just the last seven days the price of a
theorem has gone from five hundred
twenty-five dollars to just $425 that's
a hundred dollar drop and almost a
twenty percent loss and this is just a
little dip either in the last 30 days it
theorem has gone all there from 850
dollars down to 400 dollars
so just a month ago the price of a
theorem was double and two months ago
the price is almost triple and the price
of a theorem was in the eleven hundreds
now I'm not saying that mining for
aetherium isn't profitable anymore
but it definitely isn't a quick way to
make money and as a result a lot of
people are trying to exit it because
they want to invest in something that's
more long-term because the returns are
the same at this point and they want to
keep their money in something more
long-term because it's unknown what the
theorem can do next on top of this the
difficulty to - dream has consistently
been going up just in the last two
months the difficulty has almost doubled
and as a result it's not as intrigue or
profitable and this has led to much less
miners entering the mining scene and a
lot of the miners that are already there
to exit it doesn't matter how a season
of investor you are it's always hard to
keep putting more money or time into
something that's just been consistently
going down and you have no idea where
it's going to go next now there are some
people who still believe in the theorem
there's not much but there are some and
the people who do believe in it theorem
still will probably switch to ASIC
mining
pick us bit mean just a few weeks ago
revealed their new ASIC that's
specifically designed to mine in Syria
it's performance is absolutely
outstanding it produces 650 mega hash a
second while only consuming 750 watts to
put the same comparison a GTX 10 atti
which is fully overclocked and at it is
that is full power limit can only do
about 37 Megan hashes a second but it
consumes 343 watts so as you guys can
see the GTX 1080 T I consume is almost
half the power but yet it doesn't even
produce 10 percent of what does new ASIC
can mine so as a result the people who
still want to continue mining etherium
would probably switch the ASIC miner
because much more profitable and again
this is leading them to sell their GPUs
as well which can be seen in the flood
of GPUs in Amazon and eBay the price
will probably be very favorable as well
for miners because this is a machine
specifically built to mind so the
performance per dollar must be much
higher than a GPU and as a result the
people who are couldn't wanting to
continue to mine in cerium would
probably switch to this ASIC and that's
also leading to more GPUs coming on to
the market but honestly I don't think
that ASIC is really going to have an
effect because even the developers of
aetherium can see that if theorem is not
doing well and that it could die very
soon for example just a little while ago
flads ampere who is a fearin developer
made a poll that asked respondents
whether or not they would support a hard
fork that obsoletes this view ASIC minor
for etherium but what exactly is a hard
fork a hard fork is when the developers
of a cryptocurrency complete changed the
blockchain from which the cryptocurrency
was mine prior to that so this would
effectively make the new ASIC pointless
but why are you doing this and how does
this suggest that they believed that
aetherium is
well this new acing is going to make
etherium mining a lot easier and when
something is easier to get its value
also drops so in essence the reason that
the developer asked the public if they
would like to have a hard Fork is
because he knows that it theorem will
probably go down even more in price
after the release of this ASIC and so
he's trying to prevent such an
accelerated downfall from happening if
cerium literally dropped $100 just after
the review of this new ASIC
so imagine if this new ASIC was actually
released and it was widespread in the
public for mining etherium so what were
their results well 57% of the public so
that they would like to have a hard fork
and only the small percentage actually
said that they were not supported so
this shows how even the developers of
etherium believe that it to him isn't
doing well and that there must be a
change just to keep it alive so as a
result this is also influencing many
miners to sell their GPUs and recoup
their costs well please don't buy these
new GPUs that are on the market for
Amazon and eBay from the miners because
current generation GPUs are already
dropping in price due to the less demand
from GPU miners so if you buy that GPU
you're literally buying a new GPU those
used to mine and it's overpriced though
so it really doesn't make any sense GPU
prices are going down and I bet just
next month you can get that same GPU but
new for the same price so I really don't
recommend that you guys buy and use GPU
right now on top of that the next series
of GPUs from Nvidia is going to come up
very soon in July or August so if you
guys are willing to pay an inflated
price you will definitely be able to
afford next generation when it comes out
so I really recommend that you guys stay
away from you GPUs and consider buying a
new GPU once the next series comes out
or at least by current generations you
view that's new so overall
cryptocurrency prices are going down
their difficulty is going up new AC
are coming out for them and even the
developers believe that it's on downward
trend and as a result a lot of GPU
miners are cylinder GPUs to recoup their
costs or invest their money somewhere
else but just forget they're providing
you a better value than what new GPUs
all right now doesn't mean that you
should buy them because GPUs are on a
downward trend right now and if you just
be patient for a little bit longer you
can get much better value for the GPU
that you buy or you can even buy a next
series GPU in the summer so I definitely
recommend that you guys to wait even if
you guys see a great deal for a GPU and
even if it doesn't say that the GPU was
used for mining because that they could
be lying but that's pretty much all I
have for you guys this time so what do
you guys think about this are you guys
exact that this is finally happening or
do you think I have terrible comeback if
they do a hard fork make sure to comment
down below what you guys think because I
do read all my comments and I'm curious
as to what you guys think so make sure
to post your thoughts also if you guys
like this video then make sure to drop a
like and hit that subscribe button if
you guys would like to see more videos
just like this one but until next time
[Music]